hier à 23h20 m6 diffusait un nouveau
numéro d'enquêté exclusive et si
d'habitude les reportages présenté par
bernard de la villardière c'est plutôt
jeunes voyous dans les sites et cette
drogue que l'on appelle le crack
délinquance des mineurs
cette fois-ci nanar semble avoir décidé
de changé un peu de registre après avoir
révélé une trentaine de fois les dessous
du tourisme sexuel de bangkok et
l'insécurité des banlieues parisiennes
l'émission s'est cette fois-ci intéressé
aux invisibles les sdf de la capitale
vous les croisez forcément ce sont les
quelques quarante mille sdf qui habite à
paris les journalistes de l'émission
sont allés à la rencontre de ces hommes
et ces femmes qui ont tout perdu et qui
survivent tant bien que mal sur les
trottoirs dans les sous sols sous les
tunnels les rencontres et les
témoignages poignants et humain
notamment avec ibrahim sdf depuis vie
moi non plus d'un mois
cette fois ci des témoignages bruts de
ceux qui souffrent comme cette mère de
famille et ses enfants qui essaye de
tenir bon malgré une situation plus que
précaire chez compliqué comment au quick
un moment sincère loin des titres
racoleurs habituel alors enquête
exclusive at elle réussi à faire pour la
première fois une vraie enquête
ibrahim et sur notre plateau ce soir
pour nous parler de son histoire
merci brain être avec nous merci
beaucoup merci brahim k59 vont vous avez
perdu votre logement suite à une
séparation avec votre campagne
notre campagne n'est plus vos dons vos
enfants donnez plus vos enfants depuis
deux ans et aujourd'hui vous enchaînez
les endroits où dormir dans l'espoir de
ne pas être expulsé c'est ce que vous
avez dit aux portes alors on va regarder
un extrait puisque ce reportage c'est
une plongée dans les sous sol parisien
où vivent des centaines et des centaines
de sans abri et il ait brahim parmi eux
regardez où est votre abri de fortune où
l abri de fortune
ibrahim regarde ibrahim a accepté de
nous montrer où il vit son histoire est
celle d'une longue descente aux enfers
pendant dix ans couvreur dans le
bâtiment il a enchaîné les missions
d'intérim
puis un jour sa femme le quitte et part
avec leurs cinq enfants devenus
travailleurs pauvres comme près d'un
quart des sans abri il finit par perdre
son logement il ya huit mois
il trouve alors cet espace de 15 mètres
carrés sans eau ni électricité
juste au dessous de son lieu de travail
du coup le mot au jour tout pour sauver
coup le zoute plus tous extrêmement ému
de revoir ces images c'est pareil vous
inquiétez pas vraiment non je suis pas
amusé à trépas
cet abonnement de ce que vous vivez ça
fait ça fait maintenant deux ans ibrahim
tous les soirs tous les jours il se
demande comment il va vivre le jour
prochain n'est plus aux enfants depuis
depuis deux ans et ça aussi on même
plaisant parce que comme moi company a
perdu un rôle actif tu donc aller les
socios qui ont pris des enfants là ils
ont pu les deux petits devenus les
places et donc du coup moi je travaille
si nous sommes dit que nous sommes
dimanche j'ai le temps à partir du
moment où j'ai pas le temps
ce que quelqu'un dans le bâtiment tu es
fatigué à la fin de la semaine s'il faut
encore prendre le truc le 13e gala à
montréal et jusqu'à demain c'est un
baulois et prendre le train régional la
base est allé se rendre au chevet des
enfants nation ouais mais bon c'est vrai
que les associés vous donner de nous
avons envie de travailler vous êtes
couvreur le récit couvre 9 mai vu votre
situation aujourd'hui vous n'avez plus
la force de travailler tous les jours
sans pouvoir vous avez du travail que
vous avez pu trouver dans les cheveux je
suis assez la dz alain talbot d'intello
s'ils ont des failles a pas de mission
non plus quoi avec nous confirmons
m'arrange pas la situation alors ir vous
nous avez réellement bouleversé
aujourd'hui encore puisque notre
situation s'est compliquée peu à peu
nous parler de vos enfants regardez vous
les avez évoqué hier sur m6 bones tubes
en cause tous jean sèye à part subir
comme ça va mourir lance d'autres
ces deux offres qui manquent ils brême
ou sans vraiment extrêmement ému ce soit
extrêmement ému hier qu'est ce que
qu'est-ce que vous aurez ex que vous
aimeriez qu'on fasse pour vous et
aujourd'hui c'est quoi votre cri
d'alarmé
qu'est ce que vous voudriez dire au
gouvernement à nous qu'est ce qu'est ce
qu'on pourrait faire pour vous au
gouvernement je peux rien et qu est-ce
qu aujourd'hui caisse comment comment on
peut arranger les choses qu est-ce qui
qu'est ce qui ferait que vous pourrez
repartir quelques coups de pouce on peut
vous donner pour que vous repartiez un
peu un premier faux que je leur fais mes
papiers 1 et celle là seul certificat
doppelt mais si vous n'avez pas
d'adressé fixe
c'est ça qui est bon pour partir le show
papa le terrain communal à l'inalco là
je peux trouver bon comeau voilà la
bourse en simple domiciliation vous ne
pouvez pas vous pouvez pas non en fait
c'est un peu mieux ces conditions me
situation ne peut pas refaire ses
papiers
si vous n'avez pas de papiers ou pouvait
pas travailler comment avons nous pu
passer ça donc là en fait c'est sans fin
aujourd'hui vous êtes dans une impasse
mois d'automne alors je vous dis j'ai
appelé cet après midi mes équipes ont
appelé emmanuelle wargon la ministre du
logement jeux ea condamné la paix ce
soir et alors j'ai vu que beaucoup de
gens m'ont interpellé hier sur les
réseaux sociaux notamment twitter pour
mears irin est ce que tu peux aider
ibrahim plan bien entendu j'aimerais
aider tout le monde vous le savez
j'aimerais et franchement voilà si
j'avais une baguette magique bien sûr
j'aimerais aider tout le monde
ibrahim ce soir je vais appeler la
ministre du logement
je vais voir ce qu'elle peut faire pour
vous si vous pouvez et c'est peut être
d'avoir un rendez vous avec elle qu'elle
puisse essayer de démêler cette affaire
pour vous et moi j'aurais aussi une
proposition à vous faire
ensuite une fois qu'on l'a eue alors
j'appelle tout de suite emmanuelle
wargon c'est la ministre du logement et
on espère qu'on va avoir des bonnes
nouvelles
alors oui bonsoir madame la ministre
monsieur cyril hanouna
voilà vous êtes en direct avec nous je
suis pas aussi vous avez regardé
ibrahimi hier un sur m6 oui moi aussi
j'ai regardé se rapporte à l'été on va
l'aider à démêler sa situation
on veut l'aider pour voir comment lui
trouver un poids et comment aussi de
leur donner accès au droit dont il a
besoin
la santé confronté à toutes ces
situations de détresse on ouvre des
places on a un travail avec les grands
de l'association la croix rouge a eu
pour que ça cesse
alors madame amis c'est vrai qu'il ya
plein de gens qu'on a vu hier qu'ils
étaient dans une détresse
incroyable il ya vraiment très très beau
reportage d'ailleurs même si c'était
nécessaire en ce moment c'est vrai qu'il
ya plein de gens qui vont dire oui
pourquoi une prime et pas d'autres mais
c'est vrai qu'on aimerait aider tout le
monde
vous aimeriez des tout le monde là c'est
vrai que ibrahim par le fait de ce
reportage qui il a été mis en lumière et
aujourd'hui on a vraiment envie de lui
tendre la main
en tout cas nous avec la production et
vous aussi vous avez vu le reportage
c'est vrai qu'à plein d'autres gens qui
vont bien sûr se tourner vers vous allez
inverse toutes les associations il ya
beaucoup de familles qui souffrent en ce
moment
est-ce que qu'est ce que vous allez
faire pour ça parce que c'est vrai que
voilà d'ailleurs des autres
aujourd'hui encore j'étais dans un
centre d'hébergement à bonneuil dans le
mal demain d'une centaine de personnes
c'était des hommes ou des femmes une
femme en détresse qui ouvre des places
tous les jours que l'état finance on a
ouvert les honoraires 40000 places
la crise du comité s'est déplacée des
nuits à l'hôtel c'était nuit dans des
centres il en fait son temps et pas qu
juste à mettre aux gens de dormir on
leur permet à te faire leurs papiers
importants 1 point
et puis finalement c'est leur permettre
d'avoir accès à un logement c'est pas
parce que vous savez dans le reportage
d'hier il ya aussi une famille et
heureusement je crois qu'on a besoin de
continuer à construire des logements
voilà moi mon ministère on est super
moment comment faire passer pour ibrahim
il va vous allez mettre des gens en
contact avec lui avec notre production
pour que je m'en fous ces théories
d'accord avec une grande association
d'autres voir quelles solutions proposez
et quand on sait ce qu'on peut lui
proposer on prendra contact avec lui
mais dans les jours qui viennent à
trouver mais il faudrait dire aux autres
tous les jours parce que ya ceux qui
font dans un reportage qui donne une
figure à ce combat et puis il ya tous
ceux qu'on ne voit pas et qui sont là
quand même
et pour lesquels moi je me bats tous les
jours jour après jour bâtiment un très
bel hôtel après rethel qu'on cherche
confère d'ailleurs qu'ils veulent
serre et ben merci en tout cas
emmanuelle wargon ministre du logement
d'avoir été avec nous ce soir et on va
s'occuper ibrahim merci emmanuel merci
beaucoup et en asie merci merci au
revoir
alors donc ibrahim c'est plutôt des
bonnes nouvelles et moi au nom de la
production à mon nom sachez que vous
serez logés à l'hôtel à mes frais dès ce
soir
voilà donc ce soir où sera l'hôtel las
etc voilà c'est pour nous jusqu'à voilà
pendant pendant un an
voilà voilà reparti merci merci brahim
merci vous voulez vraiment vous donner
un coup de pouce et j'espère que vous
allez pouvoir repartir
et pour pouvoir travailler
merci brahim ne veut de toute façon une
fois que j'ai mes papiers a baisé
d'elana toujours l'oreille maple tout le
temps mais c est nous donne du boulot
j'ai pas de compte pas de papiers
tout ce que j'ai sûrement l'asema cap
professionnel c'est tout ce que j'ai
plus justement je veux vraiment que pour
l'instant vous soyez à l'hôtel vous
enleviez déjà ce problème est que vous
fassiez vos papiers avec le ministère du
logement puisqu'ils vont s'occuper de
vous et comme ça on peut avancer et vous
allez pouvoir retravailler et vous
remettre
voilà sur les bons rails voilà merci
ibrahim bravo et merci m6 c'est parce
que c'est grâce à eux on a pu voir le
cas d'ibrahim merci mike ibrahim
je m'occupe de vous je vous lâche pas
voilà merci beaucoup en tout cas